SUZ HINTON: I'm Suz Hinton.
I bring novelty
to existing ideas.
And this is how I code.
Right now I'm working on
a plant automation device
just because I'm going on a
long vacation really soon,
and I care about my plants.
And instead of the plants
just using the internet
to communicate with each
other, they actually
use an audio data
protocol called Chirp.
I'm laying out
like a custom PCV.
And it's going to be a
shield for a Raspberry Pi.
At the moment I've
done the schematic.
Now I just have to lay out all
the components on the board.
Try to implement
someone else's work.
The biggest growth
that I saw as a coder
was actually implementing
something from a spec.
One of my favorite
papers that I'm actually
trying to implement right
now is called Push Pull + +.
It's by Lipp, Wonka, and Muller.
And it's all about
trying to figure out
if you have a certain
amount of vertices,
how do you then grab one
face and extend it out
intelligently?
And what is the
math around that?
I'm Suz Hinton.
If you want to reach out
to me, you can actually
hit me up on Twitter.
Or you can come visit my live
stream every Sunday on Twitch.